holiday event to lift the spirits of
children with severe burns today the UMC
burn Care Center held its annual
celebration reuniting burn survivors
with the caregivers who helped them
Joshua peguero spoke with kids who are
still on a journey of healing tonight
me accuse is still recovering from Burns
she suffered last Year everybody
like really sad I was really
disappointed in myself it was a hard
time for everybody the incident left the
15 year old with a scar on her face she
says she was cleaning her jewelry with
alcohol when the bottle caught on fire
and blew up Kiehl's receives treatment
at the UMC Lions burn Care Center I just
go back to like my numeral teen I I did
volleyball and I do dance so nothing
really changed after the incident danbar
Buckland was also treated at UMC for
burns that have since healed if anyone
makes fun of your burn just ignore him
don't you you can't let other people's
words hurt you all these kids were at
the North Las Vegas fire station for the
burn Center's annual little war
pediatric holiday event Yasmine Conaway
of UMC says treatment isn't just
physical there's also the emotional part
of it the emotional healing that they
need so we have peer support the UMC
Bird Center is the only Burn Center in
the state of Nevada in the north Las
Vegas Fire Department considers in an
asset to the community and for the other
fire agencies in their area Keith
Armington is Vice President of the
firefighters of Southern Nevada burn
Foundation he's also with the north Las
Vegas fire department and understands
how important the burn center is to the
area being within the city of North Las
Vegas UMC is 15 20 minutes at the most
having a UMC Burn Center here on site or
in southern Nevada is huge the burn
Foundation gave out toys for all the
kids who attended reporting in North Las
Vegas Joshua peguero eight news now and
UMC says one of the most common Burns
they treat for children are from
pavement they say kids should avoid
walking barefoot outside during the hot
summer months